I'm the best no one's better...
Okay so we're gonna play a little quick fire questions game.
So the first one is burger or pizza
What's the first one?
Burger or pizza
Oh burger or pizza!
Like baguette or pizza, I put pizza in a bag. Pizza, Pizza Pizza
Singing in the car or the shower
Singing in the shower. I need to concentrate while driving.
Dinner and a movie or Netflix and Chill?
Awww, Netflix and Chill but of course!
Early bird or night owl?
Alley bird?
Early bird.
Oh early bird! Yeah early bird. Oh night owl.
I'm kind of more of like a daytime hawk I think.
Texts or Calls?
Phonecalls
Old school, I like that.
Beer or Wine?
Erm, bitter wine? Oh beer or wine!
Okay so I prefer wine but I don't even really drink that much.
New York or London?
Haha erm New york? No London!
I gonna have to say London right now.
Cause I'm gonna get in trouble by the London, those men in tall hats. They're gonna scream at me.
What's your favourite dance move?
Every dance move that I did in my video because I am such a good dancer.
That was a real highlight of the video by the way.
Yeah I'm the best no one's better...
I like your notecards. Yeah I like metallic. Sorry go ahead, I have like ADD, go ahead.
What's the best piece of advice you've been given?
Hmmm to make music that you would want to
hear on the radio not to make music that others do.
Number one celebrity crush?
Oh I don't know anybody who wants to
have a crush on me. I'll be happy with
you know anybody. Um most used emoji?
Any girl that thinks they can handle this... Most used emoji, the one the dumb smiley. The really cheesy one.
And finally, what's the craziest thing that's ever happened to you on tour?
The people that like come up to me and
meet and greets and I say the most like
insane and like the heart heartbreaking
like combination of everything things
like people just feel like they can open
up to me and that's that that really is
the most insane thing ever.
Well yeah that's it. Thank you
very much. Imagination.
Bye-bye!